lorsqu'il se balade en amoureux dans les
rues de paris
il attire tous les regards et pour cause
meg 29 ans et olivier 31 ans ont une
différence de taille
non j'ai déjà du mal avec monsieur
mettant des bases saines comme ça ils
s'aiment comme ça un mois
moi ça dérangerait vers le collège lever
la tête
olivier culmine à 2 m 20 à côté de son
petit ami xxl mais qui semble tout petit
un décalage qui ne passe pas inaperçu
impressionnant combien le droit et vous
me direz qu'il s'en dit voilà je vais
gérer les tékés ça vous gêne pas non ça
me gêne pas c'est demander poliment
demandé plus tôt
tous les jours avoir des gens comme ça
oui avec que je dire prendre les photos
discuter échanger là mais la plupart du
temps ce des personnes voilà qui
harcèlent qui prennent des photos à
notre insu un projet med s'est habitué à
être parfois considéré comme une bête de
foire
même si pour elle aussi au début de leur
relation
ce n'était pas si simple les amoureux
ont fait connaissance il y a trois ans
grâce à un site internet
mais qui se souvient de leur premier
rendez vous un véritable choc de loin
comme ça à l'est et une personne de
taille normale et puis ils avançaient
plus grandi c'est en fait donc voilà ce
que ça donne un peu quand quand il est
arrivé à moi
une fois qu'on était l'un à côté de
l'autre j'ai remarqué la différence de
taille qui avait entre nous qui était
vraiment j'ai pas de mots
impressionnante os était c'était
vraiment surprise une différence de
taille impressionnante comme celle qui
sépare mag et olivier à l'eau
c'est justement ce qui a inspiré le
scénario d'un homme à la hauteur sorti
en salles cette semaine avec jean
dujardin et virginie efira qui s'apprête
comme meg à faire une rencontre
déconcertante pour se reconnaître
ça va oui très bien oui et ce qui se
passe bah rien du tout jean dujardin
campe un architecte d'un mètre 36 qui
tente de séduire une avocate al allures
de mannequin
je vous invite à vivre un truc
extraordinaire
comme toutes les petites filles j'ai
rêvé du prince charmant qui serait gros
qui serait fort qui me portait dans ses
bras et son château
je veux continuer continuer quoi cette
histoire
vont-ils réussir à surmonter leurs
différences qu'en serait-il dans la
vraie vie
nous avons posé la question à l'équipe
du film qu'on peut aimer malgré les
différences physiques énormes comme
celle ci ça vaut le coup d'essayer
soit je veux dire c'est ça je veux dire
ce que rencontrait quelqu'un c'est
l'occasion de basculer dans l'univers de
l'autre et c'est ce que le film raconte
ce n'est pas simple dans le cas d' assez
c'est vraiment une question de
centimètres
oui oui c'est ça vera 80 le mec 72 ça va
ça peut aller là ça devient compliqué là
dans notre cas évidemment à l'occasion
de la sortie de cette comédie romantique
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de duos
qui s'aiment malgré leurs différences
grand écart d'âge de taille de style ou
de culture comment font-ils pour passer
outre les préjugés
quels sont leurs secrets pour vivre en
harmonie malgré tout l'amour peut-il
vraiment tous dépassé votre top level à
superbe amos a laissé jouer
ce film c'est un peu l'histoire de
christian et 2 tràng an mais c'est super
un mètre 92 sur l'année 37 artistes
réputés peint des toiles en format xxl
toutes plus grande que lui
il mesure 1 m 30 sept une quinzaine de
centimètres de moins que sa femme ait
une grande femme de méthode
première femme alors forcément cette
comédie lui rappellent leur première
rencontre
ça va oui très bien
quand je les ai vus s'est empressé elle
est belle
est-ce que je vais arriver à lui plaire
c'est au vietnam dans un pays où la
taille moyenne des hommes et de 1 mètre
63 soit 13 cm de moins qu'en france que
christian est allé chercher trang alors
la belle jeune femme n'a pas été dépaysé
alors lieu quelques cm de plus que
christian et c'est tout pour moi c'est
vraiment naturel
le couple décide de se marier un an plus
tard à saigon dans le sud du vietnam
là bas leur couple atypique ne choque
personne gérer un beau costume
c'est la wii c'est quelque chose comme
un top model dans ma famille ils ont
accepté de ma décision c'est à te dire
voilà moi je dis ok je vais marier avec
christian inertie question comme toi
comme moi
contre toute attente c'est l'entourage
de christian qui a plus de mal à
accepter cette union me rappelle très
bien avant de me marier plein de gens
ont essayé de me dissuader
parce qu'ils ont dit cette fille n'a pas
l'habitude d'être en france n'a pas une
vie en france tu vas voir ça va pas
marcher mais j'ai dit allez vous faire
voir
j'ai pris ma valise pas en carton mais
j'ai pris ma valise
je suis allé tout seul me marier et ils
étaient 160 d'un côté installé depuis 14
ans à mulhouse ils sont devenus parents
mais quand christian et 30 vont chercher
leurs enfants à l'école
ils se sentent observés il ya des
parents qui centre je sais parfois ils
regardent bizarrement parce que c'est
nous deux parce qu'on est comment
revers les autres ne pèse pas baissé de
l'oublier sinon ma vie est foutue à 8
ans sony fait quasiment la même taille
que son père
et sa fille kimmy presque 20 centimètres
de plus tout allait bien à l'école avoir
face aux moqueries un peu facile de
leurs camarades
les enfants ont appris à se défendre et
ce qu'ils ont dit récolte un peu un peu
seulement
et toi qu'est ce que tu as dit quand ils
ont dit ça parce que papa qui s'était
formée très triste et fière de sa merci
malgré tout ces railleries
le couple reste zen aujourd'hui lors du
haut est hors norme suscite même
l'admiration de leurs amis petits grands
peu importe la taille c'est voilà c'est
des gens extraordinaires
ils sont uniques et fraises attachant et
très soudée
voyez pas de différence entre eux
réveilla pas différence ni d'origine
italie quoi que ce soit il ya de l'amour
l'amour partout merci pour tout c'est
pas sympa si vous le verrez apparaître
un peu plus
vannes en bretagne cela ne se voit pas
au premier coup d'oeil mais orlan et
gilles ont eux aussi une différence qui
peut déranger
la jeune femme est amoureuse d'un homme
plus âgé que son propre père sur le port
ils prennent un bol d'air avant de faire
le grand saut
ce soir ils vont fêter leur pacs avec
tous leurs proches
une petite victoire pour ce couple
qu'une génération sépare
ah ouais j'ai 25 ans 54 ans après ya six
ans écoutez gilles mon âge a bloqué au
départ quoi j'ai un fils cas qui avait
21 ans
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu presque 30 ans
d'écart c'est quand même ça fait
beaucoup non la première réaction c'est
est repoussée parce que ça fait un peu
peur quand même moins
très mûr pour son âge la jeune femme
tombe sous le charme du guitariste et
s'accroche à lui même s'il est divorcé
et père de deux enfants
aujourd'hui le couple habite un petit
appartement dans cet immeuble
contrairement à ce que gilles craignait
leur grand écart d'âge il ne le
ressentent pas au quotidien
c'est de vraiment salon il en tête de la
face à un détail près la musique ce soir
pour leur fête de pâques ce orlan a
préparé une playlist mais il ya un petit
problème de génération td truc que
j'aime pas du tout le non pas par tient
déjà la pink njj rate ses deux lancers
au dessus de mes forces
lui est plutôt fan de rock des années 70
alors le cinquantenaire doit faire
quelques sacrifices
bon gré vous accepte dans quelques
minutes les invités vont arriver il y a
6 ans le couple n'aurait jamais imaginé
organisé une telle fête car à l'époque
leurs proches sont encore déroutés par
leurs relations
surtout le père d'orlane vous aux yeux
de jean françois gillet est alors loin
d'être le gendre idéal il est plus âgé
de moins de 3 ans 5 ans 5 ans 10 ans 66
66 65 ans ça m'a fait quoi ça m'a fait
peur sur nous sur le coup ça m'a fait
peur sur le fait de voir quelqu'un de
plus âgé qui était avec ma fille qui
avait une vingtaine d'années évidemment
ça fait on a l'impression qu'il va jouer
avec quoi et il n'a pas été le seul à se
méfier
océane et la meilleure amie d'orlane
elle a assisté à la rencontre du couple
sa première réaction a été radical était
trop vieux
ben tu imagines tu en étais moi tu
aurais dû vasif ans il a 38 ans plus que
toi n'ont pas trente huit mois à 18 ans
qui fait pas de lui un musicien est
souvent sakho la pâte elle s'amuse
autant avec lui que j'ai des gens
neutres à lons
avec le temps le rockeur au coeur tendre
a su gagner la confiance de toute la
famille
les
si orlan et gilles ont réussi à prouver
que leur écart d'âge n'était pas un
obstacle
d'autres ont plus de mal à vivre leurs
différences au quotidien c'est à
saint-aubin des bois à quelques
kilomètres de chartres que vive meg
olivier et leur bébé
une maison de 120 mètres carrés sur
mesure pour la jeune femme mais pas
franchement pour son petit ami ces
maisons normal pour des gens à dire
entre guillemets normaux donc c'est pas
adaptés à l'âge
par exemple up la porte s'ils baissent
pas la tête c'est mon esprit on déporte
assez régulièrement sopic impossible
d'agrandir les portes de cette maison en
location
alors pour le mobilier le couple
redoublent d'ingéniosité
comme avec cette table à langer
qu'olivier à fabriquer lui même à son
échelle à sa hauteur est pas la mienne
donc il me faut monter sur un tabouret
pour ce sera un match tout simplement
une table qui ne va pas servir longtemps
à seulement neuf mois le petit mais
wayne a déjà tout d'un géant du coup
comme il est grand la bi en 24 mois
alors c'est bon pour cette famille xxl
chaque geste du quotidien est une corvée
tu sais que le meuble complètement de
formule
quand olivier se contorsionne meg
déploie toutes ses forces pour atteindre
le sel qu'il a caché au fond de
l'étagère sortir la seule pièce qui
semble convenir à l'heure de gabarit
c'est la chambre ils ont investi dans le
plus grand lit du marché 2 m sur 2 m 20
ça fait comme ça à la bonne taille à
quelques centimètres près des pieds
dépassent quand même à la plage avec mes
pieds à la question qu'on nous pose
assez régulièrement c'est comment ça se
passe au lit est ce que ça se passe bien
comment je fais comment il fait parce
que c est qu au liban on n'a pas la même
taille le m'allonger mais ils ont
qu'allonger c'est plus facile que de
boucles nombreux chercheurs un petit but
donc c'est que ça marche
l'endroit olivier se sont parfaitement
bien dans ses baskets du 52
c'est au travail
le jeune homme de 2 m 20 et basketteur
professionnel dans l'équipe de chartres
sur le banc des supporters maigre
retrouve régulièrement d'autres femmes
de joueurs comme béni ce qui peut être
un problème dans la rue est ici la norme
mais la différence de taille il y en a
pas ce que là moi je suis toujours en
talons hauts si j'enlève mes talons moi
j'étais à peu près 1 m 56 1 m 93 donc
moins c'est pas grave
ça continue
finalement ces couples en sont persuadés
leur amour est à leur image version xxl